opposers I have a shocking confession I
can't do it all so I always roll with my
stranger from another manger Jesus he
follows me wherever I go that's why I
order two bloomin onions when I'm eating
alone at Outback and like any bro who
has my back
Jesus picks up the tab I assume I
bounced and I don't look back now I'm a
man and therefore in amazing driver but
sometimes the road of life gets twisty
and treacherous that's when I sit back
and let jesus take the wheel
thanks JC Conservatives know that there
are many problems on this earth that man
just cannot solve so we shouldn't try
take teen pregnancy Donald Trump
believes in abstinence only sex ed and
Donald Trump is an expert on abstinence
he always always wait to tell marriage
or until his lawyer wires them 130 grams
so Trump pulled the plug on Obama's
sinfully comprehensive teen pregnancy
program which only reduced teen
pregnancy but drop wants to eliminate it
it's how I live my life when my doctor
told me to reduce my cholesterol I did
him one better and got rid of it
completely unrelated my vision is
blurred and I smell burning toast at all
times so when it comes to sex ed
President Trump is letting Jesus
take the wheel the Trump administration
published its new pregnancy prevention
plan last week what's being said now is
the sexual risk avoidance with which is
just a different way of saying
abstinence only we believe that
abstinence only education is harmful
role ad you know you know what's harmful
a bunch of teens run it around who know
more about the vagina than I do
it's humiliating to get funding under
Trump's new proposal schools are
required to use elements from programs
like smart tool a faith friendly
curriculum that promotes abstinence by
making kids afraid of sex a tactic they
call fear arousal the idea is to make
teens horny and up for sex but for fear
it's a wedding GOP campaign strategy and
also why some jerk keeps my
jack-o'-lantern every Holloway to be
clear I'm not saying it's wrong to
jackal antics it's a safe alternative to
actual sex I'm just saying
get your own thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's jack-o'-lantern
Carl this is great
contraception has no place in schools
teens can't see a condom these days
without snorting it up their nose look
at this
hi I'm 95% sure that's not what you're
supposed to do with condoms bottom line
the only one who should be knocking up
teenage girls is God himself so to
prevent to Jesus guys Jared hey Mary
Magdalene looking up so to prevent teen
pregnancy forget the birds and the bees
and let jesus take the wheel
[Music]
yes Drive Jesus drive drive all the way
to the swamp Washington DC where Donald
Trump is under attack by deep state
forces and Jeff Sessions and rod
Rosenstein refused to take a samurai
blood oath to protect their president if
no one on earth can defend our president
we must call on divine intervention to
shield him with prayer let this fiery
televangelist lead the way God was
faithful November 9th and he spoke to me
he showed me the vision of a dome
covering the president in the executive
branch
this assignment would be ours to be a
strike force a spiritual strike force
the POTUS shield feel that charisma whoa
I haven't been this moved in church
since I learned that we're allowed to
hurl stones at people but what is this
POTUS shield you ask well who are you
Robert Moeller
it's a prayer powered force field
protecting Donald Trump and his maga
mission it's got everything
swords lions a lake of fire for some
reason and you and I can be part of the
POTUS shield by purchasing a DVD set for
a fifty five dollar donation this is
real and like all donations it's a fixed
price that you have to pay if you want
the product
and boy do I want that product here take
my money Jesus and my take my prayers
and most important take the whale it is
important to put our faith in God but
sometimes God could use some second
guessing enter Paul Ryan House Democrats
and even some Republicans are angry over
the sudden firing of their longtime
chaplains by Speaker Paul Ryan Ryan's
office complained last year that Conroy
got too political during a tax cut
debate Conroy prayed on the House floor
urging lawmakers to strive for economic
equality yes good for you Paul as Jesus
said let thy skin be the thinnest now
Ryan says the firing wasn't politically
motivated but that father Conroy just
hadn't offered enough spiritual support
to lawmakers it's a great point
did that chaplain ever once pray for the
return of Paul Ryan's missing spine no
he did not know it meanwhile some people
are running around with too much spine
like those pesky Parkland kids
why aren't you praying about that
inequality so Paul Ryan thank you for
canning this man of the cloth and
for knowing when Jesus shouldn't take
the wheel you hear me JC you turned a
few too many waters into wine but I hate
to do this but Jesus give me the keys
come on come on give me the keys give me
the keys Jesus yes
a Yaris really Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]